welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of 20 more
Easter eggs and details that I found
after re-watching black panther wakanda
forever yes I already spent over 40
minutes analyzing this movie's deeper
layers of meaning and our opening
weekend breakdown but the more time I
spend with wakanda forever the more I
find reasons to love it from subtle
tributes to Chadwick Bozeman to secrets
in the production design there's so much
more to talk about so let's go actually
take it away Riri
and thanks to boxu for sponsoring this
video more on their tasty offerings
later first assuri's opening words of
this film bust time is running out
please allow me to heal my brother of
this illness and I will never question
Your Existence again now I discussed
before how this opening prayer paints
sure he is a non-believer at the
beginning of this film but I also love
how this parallels to China and Civil
War after Chicago was killed in my
culture death is not the end it's more
of a stepping off a point to reach out
with both hands and bust segment they
lead you into the green belt where you
can around forever now that script line
was actually quoted in the new t'challa
themed Marvel Studios title imagery and
this clip was circulated after Chadwick
boseman's death in 2020 but many
continue to leave out the true context
of t'challa in that moment that sounds
very peaceful
my father thought so
I am not my father Yes t'challa in that
moment was not a pacifist or a missed it
ready to forgive
you didn't what kind of
thought just like shuri starts this film
as sure he rushes to print a
heart-shaped herb cure for her brother
later revealing that he suffered in
silence and she didn't know about his
illness until it was too late this
suggests that shuri sprinted to her lab
directly after realizing t'challa was in
his final moments and we are likely
seeing the second half of a sing with
t'challa dropping us right into the
middle of medical chaos like Monica
Rambo post split in one division now on
to the funeral production designer
Hannah beechler who won an Oscar for her
work in the 2018 film and definitely
deserves another one for this movie hit
some amazing secrets in the construction
of the wakandan street which she
referred to as a triangle pretty much
everything we see in the shot has some
deeper history or meaning behind it like
I pointed out the statues of bashinga
and his Queen while beechler revealed
that bashenga is holding an orb of
vibranium and a spear modeled on artwork
of Mansa Musa of the Mali Empire in the
14th century who is considered to be the
wealthiest person in world history even
to this day if you adjust for inflation
and I will add that in the Final Act of
this movie umbaku replaces his broken
staff with one that clutches an orb of
vibranium perhaps we're telling his
coming role as a new ruler of wakanda
meanwhile the statue of bashenka's Queen
beastler reveals has her Palms facing
outward symbolizing truth honesty and
openness now one of my favorite new
details is beyond the gate you can
barely see a Hut which is actually a
recreation of the famous Hardware Nelson
Mandela was born now t'challa both in
the MCU and more recent Comics written
by authors like tanaisikotes was
definitely inspired by Nelson Mandela
down to Marvel Studios choosing the
South African HOSA spoken by Mandela as
the spoken language of wakanda now in
that shot of the billboard showing
t'challa with the wakandan that
translates to the panther king forever
lives in us and rests with the ancestors
in a Past trailer breakdown I also
translated the letters on that yellow
building to mean wakandan Architects and
now we know the names beside it actually
translate to Jack Kirby Hannah beasler
Marley Arnold and Kelsey Brennan Jack
Kirby of course the comics writer who
co-created wakanda and a black panther
character feature the production
designer Marley Arnold is the art
director of this film and Kelsey Brennan
is a graphic designer who put a lot of
work in all this and Beachland even said
that the architectural models inside of
that building are inspired by buildings
or Marvel Comics and these are actual
settings from Fantastic Four and Secret
Wars secret wars being the end
destination for everything right now now
in the procession behind Ramona and
shuri is a cameo by Baba Maul the
drummer who plays the talking drum on
these films I already mentioned how
Jabari xim is a guy who plays the water
drum at the Watergate of wakanda
actually on Ramona's way back from the
U.N into wakanda the Royal Talent
fighter we see on the inside as Okoye
Pilots it this has actually been
redesigned with a new interior including
a purple suede couch the colors and
patterns are inspired by the p-fal the
Congo peacock now in the breakdown I
talked about how riri's dorm door
mentions the Colette's conjecture that's
one of the most famous unsolved problems
of mathematics to clarify Riri actually
wrote here solve or don't knock which is
basically saying don't knock but the
fact that shuri enters anyway May hint
that shuri has in fact solved this now
in the scene Riri references a
Metallurgy Professor who knew about her
vibranium detector project and said that
she wouldn't be able to build one but
Riri didn't know that the CIA had this
so maybe this professor was someone sus
Thursday's inside Marvel will actually
explore whether that could have been
someone important like a Victor Von Doom
PhD now after Riri throws the floor
heater at them Okoye jokes to shuri
about no more good luck defeating him
with a heater which sets up how shuri
and Riri actually will defeat no more in
the Final Act dehydrating him with
heaters preventing him from absorbing
moisture via diffusion boxu is hands
down the best Japanese snack
subscription they work with family
businesses all across Japan to deliver a
new theme of authentic treats every
month the first box will be Seasons of
Japan but after that you'll get a new
monthly theme just like this one this
month's theme is Autumn mccoyo which is
the Japanese word for the Autumn Leaves
changing colors I just love that there
is a word for that isn't that beautiful
it comes with this booklet that tells
you all the snacks you're eating where
they come from a little information
about all of them what kind of flavors
you can expect what I'm gonna try is a
matcha butter cookie dough you know as I
get older I don't really need the
overwhelmingly sweet flavors it's just
all sugar like a bit of a mix a bit of a
texture right
give it a shot
oh that's really good oh that's so good
like the flavor of this thing is not
like anything you're gonna find at like
the corner store it's Unique it's matcha
eat and it's just really nice to savor I
could eat a million of these things you
know what the really nice thing about
boxu is that when you really fall in
love with a snack you can stock up on
your favorites through baksu Boutique
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
and we love them plus every time you get
your box to in the mail you can feel
good knowing that you're supporting
family businesses all the way in Japan
so if you want to try some rare Japanese
snacks with us and support the channel
click the link in the description and
use code rockstars15 to get 15 off your
order atuma and nomura confront them on
the bridge which is my favorite fight of
the movie and at one point nomura passes
a Tuma a water grenade and he bounces it
off his hip at akoye we actually saw in
talukan they played the Mesoamerican
ball game Pete's where a rubber ball is
bounce off a hip through a hoop also in
the breakdown it talks about how the
teleconino salute reflects the telecon
Throne of an open shark Jawbone but this
is also a gesture taken from ancient
Mesoamerican hieroglyphics now as the
more explains his backstory it's worth
noting that the heart-shaped Derby his
Elder finds is actually located near the
Yucatan Peninsula in Mexico suggesting
that the second vibranium meteorite
could have been the same thing as the
Sheikh salub impact event that created
the Gulf of Mexico and killed the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago and also
theorized that could have been the same
event as the arrival of Tiamat and
vibranium could have been gifted to
Earth by the celestials and speaking of
Mexico those speculating that nakia's
outfit is a nod to Mirabelle from
Encanto that ain't no Easter egg no no
no no no I tried to make her work didn't
really fit anyway I think this is
doubtful because inconto is set in
Colombia and Nakia is in Mexico right
now two distinctly different cultures
and histories not everything Disney is
also Disney but a little detail I'm
pretty sure this movie is that whenever
no more attacks wakandan airships in
this movie like when he slices him with
a spear mid-air those ships don't
explode they just slice in half and drop
down and that's because all of this Tech
is vibranium based it's not powered by
fossil fuels and combustion engines
these parts are otherwise indestructible
so they totally would not go boom you
looking for this Nakia visits okoya
outside her house which Hannah beachler
said wasn't inspired by the Great
Zimbabwe a structure thought to be part
of a capital of a great City during the
Iron Age which is an homage to actress
deny guerrera's home ancestry now in The
Final Duel nemour says in his native
Mayan language emporious Rex which is
Latin for Emperor King but it's really
an expression no more says in the comics
kind of his Battle Cry and as Sherry
forces no more to yield she says
vengeance has consumed us and will not
let it consume our people and she's
calling back t'challa's words to Zemo at
the end of Civil War Vengeance has
consumed you he's consuming them
don't letting it consume me and in that
moment we saw t'challa's claws retract a
contrast to shuri's claws coming out
when she first charged it no more now
two number-based Easter eggs that we'll
close out with the home in Haiti where
shuri greets Nakia in the final scene is
numbered 1804 in 1804 is the year Haiti
gained independence from France and this
Independence effort of course was led by
Tucson again I'm sorry for my French
Haitian pronunciation it's terrible I
know but this guy awesome black Napoleon
father of Haiti whom Nakia and t'challa
took t'challa Jr's Haitian name from and
in the penultimate scene when Okoye
rescues Everett Ross his transport band
license plate reads CB 11 2976 which is
a tribute to Chadwick Boseman CB whose
birthday was November 29 1976. I love
this detail now that's all the new stuff
I found if I didn't mention in this
video it's probably in the other big
breakdown that is over the weekend go
check that out you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at EA boss
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you